regression was first used in 1805 by
lissandra who doesn't have a nice
painting of him on Wikipedia so I picked
the one for the second person to use it
in 1807 yes so that's more than 200
years ago this has been around for a
really long time and it's still a really
popular standard approach to machine
learning today so let's have a look for
our example we will be making smoothies
every smoothie will have 1 cup of plain
yogurt one secret ingredient that a
bunch of random food dye so that you
cannot tell what is in there I blend it
up I serve it to you and your goal now
is to shout at me what are the calories
in this smoothie go what do I hear 100
going once going twice
300 500 now I'm doing a little test here
seeing who's got the strongest aptitude
in the audience for machine learning
because the machine learning attitude is
not the attitude of perfectionism ah
think carefully and get the answer right
on the first go and don't even try it
unless it's going to be perfect now the
attitude is go for it see what happens
get it wrong because you're going to
have to do it over and over again you're
gonna fail fall down over and over again
pick yourself up try again until finally
it works and you have to try something
to know what to do next
and so if you're too afraid to start you
tend not to do well in applied machine
learning so those of you who were brave
enough to just go for it even though you
didn't know the right answer yeah that
was what's gonna get me to move to the
next slide and give you more information
and will be able to iterate towards
correct together okay so you've unlocked
the next slide turns out this was what
was the secret ingredient $58 grams of
sardines
with 265 calories in there lovely I see
you don't want to drink it fine it make
you a different one yes the calories now
8400 hundred and eightieth alright I'm
hearing some more responses and
rumblings now let me tell you what was
in here 50 grams of not delicious
waffles that I've shown you in the
picture no no the raw stuff waffle mix
and this is actually in a mosh to a
standard hazing experience that happens
on the fifth floor of the Google office
here in New York which is most new
Googlers myself included I've done this
you done this then you walk up and you
see this delicious smoothie and you try
it and it is not a smoothie so standard
newbie hazing experience here okay so
you don't want to drink this one fine I
make you a third one but before I make
you guess I'm gonna give you a little
more information this is the 16th
smoothie that I've made and here are the
15 previous calorie amounts your first
reaction to this should be not trying to
read it but instead stepping your foot
and saying I'm a human I don't that
numbers up that's what machines are for
indeed correct so the machines gonna
help us out and summarize them and we
find out that the average is 237 and the
middle thing is 214 have a guess now as
to the calories of this one 237 I'm
hearing to 38 to 40 notice how your
range has narrowed a whole lot as I give
you more information that's gonna be key
to our discussion okay I'll go for 237
ah it turns out to be 88 grams of quiche
Lorraine clocking in at a whopping 445
calories and proving to us that any
liquid diet is beatable
so how did we do we had an under
estimate of 208 calories with that
strategy and can we do better well maybe
it would help to have the weight of the
secret ingredient so what we'll do
as analysts ears we'll make a little
plot and we'll have the weight from 0 to
200 grams on the x-axis and calories
from 0 to 500 on the y-axis and as we
look at this we ask ourselves is there
anything going on or is weight
completely useless here what do you
think completely useless something to it
and since there's something to it maybe
we'll go ahead and we'll try it out
shall we
and regression is about putting lines
through stuff so why don't we put a line
through it like that line good line huh
we missed uh where should we put this
line by the way those who forgot how our
lines work here's a handy cheat sheet
the recipe of the model is simply
intercept plus slope times the weight so
we'll have two numbers here in red that
we have to find or discover that
determine where the line goes and then
we pop the weight in there and read the
calories off of it so that's what we're
dealing with the straightforward stuff
so you don't like my win okay fair
enough how about that one you don't like
that one this one it's a tough crowd
that one no this one
you look offended why you look offended
by this
each cuz let me remind you of something
real quick this right here this is your
previous model and now you're offended
but before you were very happy to just
guess 237 every time 237 and 0 times the
weight means I ignore the weight and say
237 every time and you were so fine to
use it then check your feature
engineering privilege what is feature
engineering that's when we create inputs
so that we might use to learn from stuff
that might inform our solution and when
we have a feature that we might use
suddenly we can do better
so that's kind of gonna be the point
as we get information that's going to be
relevant to solving this thing we expect
to do better in Burien it's gonna be up
to us to think about what information
might be worth putting into the system
in the first place okay so let's do
better if we can do better we're going
to find a line that's as close to the
points as possible because you seemed
offended when I wasn't doing that
fine so we'd better define a notion of
an error what's an errors is the point
minus the line the truth - what we were
saying we should predict and because we
all have Type A personalities here we
hate errors so we are going to minimize
a function of these errors and that is
going to be the score for how this thing
performs and a good score is to have
fewer errors and we will use the rmse
here and this thing is very creatively
named it's actually the recipe for
calculating it backwards get the error
square the error take the mean or
average and take the square root of that
root mean squared error or MSE okay or
you could just think of the our MSE as
the calories were off by on average not
technically correct but good enough for
government work we're off by about 85
calories on average and that'll do that
that's fine for for a morning okay so
now we're off by 85 and we want to be
off by fewer so let's see if we can just
jiggle those two red parameters there in
the recipe to make things better when
you want to do maybe you want to
increase the slope a bit okay that's
getting better good how about we
increase the slope a little more man not
so much better
maybe now we want to move the intercept
down so let's do that and what we could
do is we could continue tinkering with
these two numbers in red with slow
boring tinkering or we could get on with
it so what are our options just play by
hand with those two numbers which is
what we were doing all we could use
calculus but who even does calculus
anymore so old school
or we could just use an optimization
algorithm to get us the answer
immediately so what is an optimization
algorithm do it says for this setting
you are trying what's your goal you are
trying to get this function right here
to be as low as possible let me figure
out for you what settings on those two
parameters that I'm allowed to play with
give me the best possible performance
here and then it outputs you that answer
and that's going to be in the heart of
every machine learning algorithm so
we're going to need to know what the
scoring is what the goal is and then
it's gonna figure out where to set the
free parameters in the recipe based on
that okay great and we have come a long
way I'm impressed with us nice let's
look at quiche Lorraine though it's
taunting us we did not predict quiche
Lorraine well how did we do better our
under estimate has gone down okay can we
do even better can we well oh there
ain't no such thing as a free lunch
she says that Google to do better we
actually need something else so what is
it gonna take we need any guesses more
information exactly I'm sorry very
nicely put because that says two things
at once more information in the sense of
just more of the same data or more
information in the sense of other kinds
of information that might be helpful you
know that's more features features in
this setting refers to variables
attributes in other settings so I'm
gonna be generous and I'm going to give
you the fat percentage how do you feel
about that that's gonna be helpful all
right so let's see so this is what we
were working with before this is a
foeman we just had to muck about with
these two parameters here and we used an
optimization algorithm to set them and
notice who here's taken a stats course
of some kind and you probably saw a
regression
it was an entirely different story in
that course the way that you were going
about it it was all this other stuff
about what it means and P values and T
tests none of that is relevant here all
we are trying to do is optimize that
function to set these two numbers so
that the difference between the calories
predicted and the actual calories is as
good as possible that's it that's all
there is to it much much simpler than
what the stats course did so there we go
those are our answers lovely no it's not
going to be a line anymore if we add fat
percentage it's a bird it's a plane same
structure just we had another one of
these right here and now the only
pertinent thing for you to realize is
that there are three widgets to tinker
with nice and plotting it there we need
to add a dimension I can't make heads or
tails of this it's a little shout out to
better plotting how about adding color
okay still not enough because I can't
see what's going on with color is more
calories gets redder but I I can't see
what's going on with this fat percentage
and weight plane so okay now I can kind
of see what's going on and if you're
used to looking at these things you kind
of see the punch line that's coming but
even if you don't see it let's find out
what happens if we run the algorithm so
again our job is to get those three
numbers to be as good as possible we
have our three options I pick they're
getting on with it and so we have this
mosquito netting fitted through our data
for us what is it trying to do get as
close to our points as possible and
those are the numbers that do it quiche
Lorraine is still taunting us how did we
do we are now off by 47 calories on
average before it was 49 I don't know
I'm not feeling it I had to double the
number of ingredients into my recipe and
all I get for that is this measly tiny
improvement maybe after all this isn't
such a promising direct
to going maybe I would prefer the
simpler model but of course don't worry
about that too much you can always try
both of them in a new data set and see
which one is working better so how are
we doing so far using only the mean
there's our under estimate with simple
linear regression that means one
ingredient
we've improved and only a slight
improvement with multiple linear
regression that means more than one
input into the model all right I'll take
your question can you do a model that
does fat percentage times weight
absolutely and there's a good reason to
think about doing that like the bit
about the water amount over the secret
ingredient we didn't even cover that
right if I just add if I just dilute the
the secret ingredient I can mess about
with the fat percentage so but the the
reason that's a good one it's a good one
the the the reasoning around whether or
not you should go ahead and try a model
like that is does it take a long time to
try it if no just do it even if you
don't have a solid of a logical argument
try it anyway you can always try
something like that and yes it's very
very easy to adjust the method to input
something like that you just make the
feature by multiplying them first and in
it goes job done
so certainly could try that okay can we
do even even even better even better
than that sure how about if I'm really
generous this is non-alcoholic and I'm
gonna give you the fat in grams the
carbohydrate in grams and the protein in
grams of our secret ingredient too
anyone want to spoil the punchline for
us who knows about nutrition let's have
it 9 4 & 4 the magic numbers because we
as humanity have figured out a whole lot
about nutrition and we already know the
answer
well doesn't matter if we know the
answer why don't we see if we can
recover that same answer from this data
set with machine learning but yeah let's
hope that our final answer is gonna look
something like that answer so here we go
this thing is now not a plane anymore
it's now a hyperplane
so let's go ahead and plot it that's not
there's no real reason to be plotting it
here because at the end of the day the
way that we check how well we're doing
how we get that score that we're
optimizing it happens the same way no
matter what is in here all we need to
know about is that we take what's
predicted we compare it with the truth
and we see how we did
and inside this thing however beastly it
is there are some numbers that we are
allowed to tinker with and we'll use an
optimization algorithm to do the
tinkering for us and hopefully some
researcher somewhere has written that
optimization code so we don't have to
that's a much better thing to spend your
time on if you're in a research division
or research in industry or research
division in academia good and they have
and so we don't have to worry about it
all we need to know is for things to
tinker with we'll still assess the
results of the same way doesn't matter
what's there so let's get on with it and
use that optimization algorithm which we
don't need to know how it works and
there you go how did we do 9 4 4
something like that looks pretty good to
me
FDA by the way confirms what you say
this is a quote from their website
carbohydrate provides four calories per
gram protein 4 and fat 9 so a very good
general knowledge
what on earth is
this 1:43 thing well we asked ourselves
if there is no fat no cops and no
protein if our secret ingredient was
water what's left well there was yogurt
in there every time now it turns out our
yogurt base had 145 calories we're
predicting 143 has a little bit of a
mismatch so maybe there was some error
in our data but you know what our score
is getting pretty good not perfect
pretty good we're off by 4 calories on
average when it used to be 47 and this
is again a shout-out to feature
engineering the fact that you had the
knowledge about this domain and realized
that having the weights in grams of all
of these things is going to be useful
that is the reason that you get a model
that's this good in the end it pays off
you can convert your domain knowledge
into good solutions and how did we do in
the end our under estimate for quiche
Lorraine is only 4 calories I say good
enough let's drink it
you